Rob here with a gamespot news update if
you were starting to get sick of call of
duty you're out of luck there's a new
movie on the way gaming giant Activision
Blizzard has announced the formation of
a new business division focused on
bringing its numerous popular franchises
to film and television the unit is
called Activision Blizzard studios and
his first projects will be call of duty
movies and a Skylanders TV show leaving
Activision Blizzard Studios is Nick Van
Dyke who formerly worked at Disney for
more than nine years as its senior vice
president the Skylanders TV show is
called Skylanders Academy based on the
franchise the animated program will
feature the voices of some popular
actors and celebrities and its
showrunner is Eric Rogers of futurama
the toys to life Skylanders series has
generated three billion to date
including 250 million toy sales some of
the talent for the Skylanders show are
as follows justin long ashley tisdale
jonathan banks and norm macdonald there
are fewer details available about the
call of duty movies however Activision
only said that it is creating a robust
Cinematic Universe for multiple movies
which could hit theaters or digital
channels in 2018 or 2019 the call of
duty movies and Skylanders TV show make
up Activision Blizzard Studios initial
lineup Activision mentioned Diablo
Starcraft and hearthstone and its
announcement but no specific movie or TV
show plans for these franchises were
announced are there any Activision
franchises you'd like to see turn into a
movie put in the comments and for all of
your gaming news you gotta gamespot com
you